welcome everybody it's friday
may the 13th
2022
and we are live what's up what's up
what's up what's up what's up what's up
what's up what's up
what's up
bitconnect you know it's funny the big
connect meme um
[Applause]
lunacoin
luna coin was like the fourth biggest
crypto and it was trading at like 80
bucks like last week and it went to zero
people lost
i see everybody talking about it well
crypto there was like there i mean there
was a huge crash with crypto and the
stock everything crashed
but luna
do you know do you understand what
happened with that dan not really
i honestly don't because i haven't
really read it and doesn't understand
what happened
i haven't really read up on it i just
saw i guess i'm curious to know but like
ksc made a tweet
he was like i just i had two million
dollars and luna and it's now worth a
thousand bucks it was almost three
million it was two i actually have it in
the dock
are we talking about like real money oh
yeah
oh yeah well the market the market cap
2.8 million is literally worth
a thousand dollars i just bought 39
million shares of safe moon so
is that his new identity
ksi krypto i think what is this
is that the same ksi yeah he has i i'm
sorry to say
i like ksi
you know
but
these influencers who are all in on this
crypto stuff is just so cringy to me
i mean come on guys
but i didn't i don't think anyone
expected that level of uh own
would you understand it love yeah
i i believe it crashed because it's
linked to like a stable coin
which is supposed to be stable and
linked to the us used dollar
and somehow i guess
because something i don't remember the
reason why that crashed but when that
crashed
uh and it lost all its value and luna
also crashed because luna is linked to
that coin interesting
yeah so this is always supposed to be
one dollar always but it like well how
did that one crash
probably because
they're supposed to supposed to like
stay because of an algorithm
i
i don't know more than that though
nobody understands it let's be honest
it's designed to make us all feel stupid
you know what i realize crypto and nfts
are like it's like money musical chairs
you just put your money in hopefully
when it's low
and then you sell when it's high and you
just hope the music don't stop and
you're left without a [ __ ] chair
it's money musical chairs that's it
i mean come on now oh gabe is here gabe
have you
oh
[Applause]
gabe who are you boxing this weekend
[Applause]
we're wishing ab good luck babe yeah
let's see it
good form baby ow
ow ow would you box me gabe for charity
kissing my ass
pissing my ass baby
would you box me for charity uh gabe i
feel like we'd be a good match-up
oh yeah
yeah i mean there there's someone i
would i would accept the other fight
with you know
oh yeah
dang you got good moves show me some
show me your best uh show me your left
right
oh damn i don't want none of that heat
i don't want any of that heat
smoke show over there hey gabe
whoa
you're going to cause a fire with all
that
friction
all right gabe adam
i love it
it's friday baby
is sure
castle that's the same white castle is
like an east coast hamburger joint oh
okay okay
oh
but yeah that is an interesting uh
observation ela i mean white castle
white claw any connection
it's just the first name is white
yeah we like that right
let's see that let's see that uppercut
oh
that's a knockout dang
pissing my ass baby
i feel like we can't hear him
no the audio's quite bad but that's part
of the charm
ow
show me your show me your strongest
punch if you're look going for the
knockout
oh
no
nobody's getting up from that one
gabe
white club white castle gabe today
all right
friday baby
friday
right gabe are you going to watch the
fight
oh yeah it's going to be a good one
fried chicken saturday
what the [ __ ]
oh fried chicken saturday you guys what
the [ __ ] baby can we get fried chicken
tomorrow oh he cut out well we got the
idea
wait are you still there gabe
how are you oh you are still there
all right well you have a great weekend
happy to see you on this beautiful
friday as always
thanks for wishing our boy ab some good
luck and
i don't want any of that smoke all right
put away those deadly weapons before
someone gets hurt definitely
hey i'm pretty sure you have to register
those with the police those guns all
right
gabe whiteclaw gave everybody
[Applause]
yes
um before we get started
a little top of the show
announcement
that
teddy fresh new collection is live
work it work it work it
you know this hoodie i made i was really
we were all feeling a little insecure
about it sold out
let me show i'm wearing this one this is
ela's original design
staying home tonight baby
this t-shirt is called i'm completely
alone isn't there a backstory to this
uh no just feelings wasn't wasn't it
about that one whale that like there's
like one whale whose frequency is off
and he can't communicate with any other
whales
um that's a great story
that could definitely apply oh i thought
i thought it was about you know that one
whale it's like the saddest loneliest
animal on earth
it's a real whale who has like a birth
defect where his
frequency of his and that doesn't sound
familiar
yeah they can't other whales can't hear
he's he's completely alone
[Applause]
um
so we've got that one
this is the one i'm wearing staying home
tonight baby
oh oh oh oh oh
you any backstory here
i don't like to interpret art okay don't
interpret art we have the
uh the interpretation is this is what it
is and what you want it to be
heavy lies the crown
we all know how that feels right
gabe knows how that feels
more than anyone
this shirt's really cool too petty to
live too pretty to die who can relate
anybody
no one all right well these cats can
relate
thank you guys
what else poppin
what else is poppin this is gone
the pants are still there also i should
say the women's
we made a women's hoodie
with the uh woman's fit
so if you're interested we still oh i
guess it's different it's a simplified
version
this belt that you're wearing today is
sick you want to show it off
i thought that came out so nice
and this is like a faux leather tip
the yeah that part yes
we only eat cows folks we don't uh
use them in clothes
and then just kind of a basic look you
know
a nice applique
and it comes in all these wonderful
colors
yeah work it work it work it
teddyfresh.com this is a all timer right
here
i wish this was made for men i would
wear it
right and that is actually something
that we have been
discussing
about next year because you know it
takes time until what we do now will
actually come out but
um
we're changing everything to be more
unisex bro i would wear th that's this
beautiful hoodie right and that's kind
of part of my uh i feel like when we
introduced women's
um
there was a bit of a learning curve on
like what is the actual difference
between the men's collection and the
women's collection
and
we started out everything being unisex
then we did that and now i feel like i
just want to go back full circle and
just be a unisex brand
and still have like if we feel like
making a crop top we'll still do it yeah
but
we're gonna start looking at everything
as a more unisex interesting picture
so if you make a hoodie like this will
the silhouette be
more skewed
it would be more towards men the fit but
it will go down to like extra extra
small i see and we will shoot it on both
men and women body types so that you can
see
love this man how it might fit on you
well there you go four women they got
the pants this one's back in stock
gone but not forgotten of course
the dino sweater
oh you know there's something else i
wanted to showcase these socks that came
out are dope dude yeah super cute those
came out so nice looking
and then the other one is these sexy
lace socks whoa not lace but it's here
the sexy sheer
showing off some toe wicky feet
no actually not trying to talk to me
baby talk to me come on out
the handcuff restocks i know a lot of
people
were asking about those so this is the
bracelet and necklace
and these tie-dye socks are actually so
sick too
good socks this drop eh
i definitely want some of these grab me
granny these dang buddy anyway
teddyfish.com heading
over there
if you want to support the show
we have no sponsors today thank you
also just a quick reminder this saturday
tomorrow
at 3 p.m we are going live for members
only
live watching
the fight that ave is participating in
dad is participating matt watson all of
our friends we're going to be watching
all of them
compete so join us it's going to be a
good good good good time
great time some say the best one some
say the dicey this time
we'll do it live i'm just going to do
that to you the whole episode today yeah
yeah you know i had a dream like what is
that it's a brendan schub
backing up joe rogan i love that clip
you guys a little bit dicey is some say
the dice
um i had a dream last night that a b won
his fight wow that he crushed the guy
actually isn't that weird
it's not weird
because that's what it's going to happen
your dream's going to come true man
that's right well it's i guess is it
isn't it weird that i'm dreaming about
it
let's go do you dream about ab on a
regular basis i haven't remembered a
dream i've had in years
but this one stood out i've never
dreamed about a b for the record unpack
that a little bit
but i dreamed that he won his fight
so there you go i'm rooting for him
both consciously and subconsciously
so nobody accused me of not supporting
him any of you having dreams about him
winning i didn't think so who who
amongst you subconscious is rooting for
him exactly
dad of course when we had that on he
said he made a body bag for his opponent
matt watson
well he actually did
and he tweeted it
matt county corner
so the gear the ring gear was shipped to
me so
he's bringing this and you know if he
dies he dies right
pretty ruthless man yeah that is a
ruthless competitor some say the most
ruthless some do you say that
sometimes
something is the most ruthless list
what has about oh post weigh-in so
they're weighing in in like a hotel
lobby what's going on here
well
i think this is the official weigh-in
and then there's like a like a more
traditional uh
broadcasted one that's tonight here's
hundar
[Music]
haydee's opponent
soon to be
dad of course is flaunting his body
i'm just saying that naked there's honda
over there oh he's recording there
but dad of course is naked as always
collection
i mean hey if you look like that
we are in the middle of a weigh-in
as always
did you notice the uh underwear that
he's wearing yeah oh that's the great
okay
matt watson can't help but if he if he
looks that good the man is jacked the
man has like no body fat i think you
need to get down to that for the way in
too uh oh it's his opponent oh yeah
because matt watson is not a heavy well
i think you need to like strip down your
underwear or
shorts too yeah so there's no excess
weight i just don't think they
everybody else is naked so yeah he's the
only one naked there right
but that's okay we love that we love
that for him as always
you know dad is interested in being the
bachelor he told me if we have a return
season
dad as bachelor ladies and gentlemen are
you going to be able to change the name
to add
to yeah i'm sure he'll use his real name
okay i'm already taking my pants off
you know it'd be funny if we got him
like a a hair system
just to see
send him over to turkey like sam was
interesting just get him no you know not
not a hair transplant oh that's like the
hair system really like
the wig that you're wearing
and everything like i got you
like a toupee or like yeah
like bosley
no like a really professional toupee
i don't see that as a
plus ever i just want it just for a goof
not really as a not not trying to make
them look better i have to make sure
nobody misunderstood that
yeah the toupee thing is pretty wild uh
but hey whatever you got to do you know
so there you go really excited about
that
hey um did you guys
did you guys hear that a new masterpiece
dropped last night
yes
that's been the buzz all over the
internet like it's crazy going viral man
what is
the masterpiece that you're talking
about
what are what are you thinking about
kendrick's album or something
no i'm not talking about kendrick
lamar's album i'm talking about
this new wally p video just dropped
oh you guys thought i was talking about
ken nick lamar's album
we were playing along with your bit and
i'm doing the bit now you guys didn't
set me up what do you
so were we
i know but one of you guys was supposed
to say kendrick lamar and i go no wally
you gotta say you guys gotta lay me up
so i can dunk it like kendrick lamar is
a new album thank you a little bit late
but then i try to pull it off and you
guys go we're doing a bit well i thought
i thought we it's a zillion zonk on the
audience i don't like i feel like a
world joke we're just doing a joke i
thought we were all in cahoots here
though we are we were supposed to be in
the boots but we were all supposed to be
on the same side of the kahooten you say
this is a comedy podcast
i thought so but apparently this is
[ __ ]
it's like dissecting a frog over here
there was like a whole premeditated joke
here
no not kendrick lamar this new wall-e p
video
again you guys were in on the joke so
there's no need to exaggerate oh and
scene
i'm leaving i'm going home
all right anyway here's the video of
muhammad robin wally stop laughing
yeah so this guy i don't know how we've
been trying to get in touch with
robbie rabib
uh but wally but i don't know this guy
he managed to get a hold of him
and he's been doing videos with him all
week now i didn't know he was such a
unit and i didn't know he was in a
wheelchair either
so already there's a lot happening
and wally is just as much the character
as we dreamed he would be have you been
able to get in touch with this guy or
anything zach
yes oh really
i
i have
uh
there's i guess reasons i should tell
you off the air
interesting um so i think i should just
leave it at that okay interesting wow
okay interesting wow intrigue
some say the most intriguing
some woods
[Laughter]
someone make a mega clip of dan just
riding my
except when dan does it somehow feels
patronizing it's not supportive like
when brandon does it
i don't feel hyped up all right i'll
work on that i'll work on the tone
anyway let's watch
youtube
make sure to like and subscribe
that's really good
[Music]
like a pokemon
while they pee i love how he was turning
and he goes wally
[Laughter]
so you know
this is possibly a new golden age of
wally p content that we're leading into
so
kind of just nice and exciting uh thing
to learn on this beautiful friday you
know i was wondering why the plastic bag
over the
head piece on this on the mobility
scooter
[Laughter]
that's interesting what's happening
there
any theories i can't possibly think of
one
other than to keep it clean but i don't
even know
like uh cultures who where they like
just plastic everything like couches and
stuff like that
yeah we've seen that
yeah
yeah okay well it's hard to put the
plastic back over the whole thing
well maybe someday we'll get to ask him
that would be a dream
yeah that's the dream interview we could
end the show after that yeah really
um
everybody's saying head grease
you think really that dude's just got
wild head grease and he knows it it's
like the area that you barely even touch
he's just protecting from head grease i
mean that's just drastic with the pla
but you know what
maybe different people different
cultures you know
here in case anyone was wondering is
this the real channel here i'm gonna
subscribe this is the real mohammed
robert wally official
usa
this is not my new youtube channel
and everybody following this account
quality okay
this guy's magic and a bottle man
i think he should be my new podcast host
oh [ __ ]
no but about kendrick have you guys been
listening to the kendrick album
yes it dropped last night at midnight
right
or something midnight on the east coast
what you guys been thinking about it
it's pretty anticipated uh release there
five years in the making
i absolutely loved it
yeah yeah
very good it's good i feel like um
it's one of those albums that we're
gonna listen to more and more and then
like it more and more the more we listen
to it that's what i'm thinking because
there's a lot to unpack with his albums
it's like
it's heavy duty stuff
usually i'll listen like a couple times
just to listen to the music
and now i'm listening more to the words
but he's touching on really like
interesting subject matters that
i think the point like a lot of it's
about like trauma
he was giving he gave out a shout out to
like trans people which was like super
[ __ ] unexpected but that was such a
great song
and just like homophobia and transphobia
in the black community
uh really
also there's one
i need to listen that song again but was
there one where he said that he was
molested or that seemed to be my take
away from it as well and yeah it's part
of there was basically like a four song
run at the end i mean the whole album
seemed very introspective but the the
four songs in a row at the end were all
very heavy
and um
and very dark but uh really illuminating
and um i was actually i was super caught
off guard because in one of those last
songs there was
a a featured female vocalist
and as i was listening to him like this
sounds
just like uh this woman beth gibbons
who's the lead singer of this band
portishead than i'm a huge fan of and i
looked it up and it's her uh which was
just like such a shock
um
i think it's
let's see i'd have to look at the threat
but yeah that run of songs at the end
dan is like was so powerful and just
like unexpected and
the way he talks about like generational
trauma
and how
like mother i sober is the name of the
song he talks about like how everyone
how he has daddy issues and
he's just talking about like a lot of
people you know
a lot of like young black men
and women
have a lot of these uh
they don't you know i don't think they
take uh
in general these really hard guys who
like uh ruled with gangs and grew up in
really hard lives
have like ptsd
they've had all these terrible things
happen to them and they don't actually
ever talk or take mental health
uh seriously
and i think it's it's actually really
a good message and really brave of him
to open up about some some of the stuff
they open up about was really surprising
that one about just like uh
how he was i guess again i haven't read
the lyrics i only was listening to it so
i have to go back
but about how he i think he was saying
that he was molested and a lot of other
people he knows in his family were
and how it affected them i mean it was
really powerful
the one song where it's like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] thank you yeah thank you
interesting i kind of love that
it's [ __ ] bad
it's like yeah
it's crazy pretty interesting yeah
but that's what i always love about him
so much it's so much like art definitely
he puts more effort than anyone like
dude takes so much time to make sure
every track and the whole concept of the
album is so
like perfect i mean every you know word
and every note is right in
in the right place you know he's he's
controlling every aspect of this album
and his messages are very uh
thought out and like just well
constructed
what what i really like about
him is i like to compare kendrick's
vocal style rapping and music it's very
jazzy and
i always picture his vocals and
lyrics like a trumpet
so it's really free-flowing but also
very
on par and it's just it's just jazz it's
really cool
that's what i love about it
but you know i gotta listen to it a lot
more yeah
but i do think it's probably gonna end
up being one of his best
albums one of his most memorable albums
it's so hard to top to pimp a butterfly
and damn that was so good i love dan but
it wasn't that well res i mean it was
because he's kendrick lamar there's like
a high bar there's a high i thought damn
was amazing i loved it i listened to it
so many times i think this album is
better than damn right on the face i
think better in that it's
i think
i think it goes further in terms of
of a
concept and musically i mean danny had
some really bangers on it like it slaps
got so many hits damn
damn has a lot of hits but we'll see you
know i think it takes time for these
things to shake out i have to listen to
a lot more yeah definitely a masterpiece
though
what i like is um
that i mean
don't know if i
necessarily like but it's i kind of
expected it to be really dark because of
all ever like the whole
last few years in everyone's life has
been so dark interesting yeah and so
that was my expectation for what it's
going to be from kendrick and i feel
like it is and i personally kind of like
it because
it really does represent
everybody's
past few years
in my opinion
it's been it's been dark like you know
pandemic and
just everything going on in the world
super interesting man
yeah and then he liked to
he really said trans rights dude
i mean it was there was like
he does like wokeness in a way that's
not i don't know it's it's kind of a
woke album but i don't know if
not in a way that i don't think anyone
will think is like
because people use that word woke kind
of a derogatory
but i don't think it's like
that definitely a masterpiece though i
think because it's actually good
it doesn't count on just being woke to
be good you know what i mean
it's good on its own and then the woke
messages within it
also kodak black is on there which i
didn't i'm not necessarily a fan i'm not
i don't listen to kodak black at all but
i don't know if
sorry
uh i don't listen to him at all but he's
really good on the
on the album he kind of tells the story
throughout the album really interesting
ian what are your thoughts
uh yeah i i liked it um sam and i drove
around and listened it a few times and
um
it's great there's a lot a lot to take
in we
every friday when music comes out we go
and listen to all the new music wow look
at you i don't know
that's like a thing we do but um
we finished the record and then we went
and listened to some of the other stuff
that came out and like no
not to hate on them but it was like we
turned we were like we can't listen to
this like it's
he's on such another level with this
yeah there's so much
layers just just how it sounds it's so
thought out and detailed and
you hear new things with each listen so
100 can't compare you know he's one of a
kind
yeah you guys should listen to it man
it's really good kendrick's the i mean
he's the best nobody's making music like
him and uh
it's just a whole experience man it's
it's great
you guys talking about the new wally p
okay video yeah it's it's powerful i'm
telling you there's just so much to take
in the most powerful it's just so cool
to have somebody like wally create
content in our lifetime you know honored
yeah
on it honored to be alive at this time
am i crazier is the screen sideways not
are you guys
it does look sideways a little bit right
a little bit yeah
a little bit sideways today guys but it
is friday
are you crazy are you out of your mind
it's so weird when we don't have ads
like i don't have to pause for anything
i just keep going and going and going
and going and
i think maybe we need to come closer
together
[Music]
let's go
let's let's let's go let's go
let's go
all right
i'm too much fun can i just say why i
have a genuine question
question to everybody why is jack harlow
everywhere
everywhere hot right now what is
happening
he's having i don't know who he was like
two weeks ago and now it's everywhere
sam likes him so
carlo is very charming
okay but why is he everywhere
i'm charming are you guys
are you guys experiencing this moment
right now i've been i don't ever talk
about him online or anything but i am
getting every like jack harlow tweet
tick tock like i don't follow anything
related to him so it's super weird it's
so weird right yeah it's an industry
plant
clearly there's a conspiracy
i mean it seems cool yeah he seems
really nice and cool so yeah to the guy
no hate at all but i'm just like what is
it sometimes they push someone so hard
and it just you get over it like ryan
reynolds i have no problem with ryan
rounds but i'm [ __ ] tired i think
it's gotten better but that [ __ ]
was in every
[ __ ] movie for a minute and i was
like i was like i am not going to
another ryan reynolds film
he's on everything in netflix
god
what is this should i open this hand he
has a fantastic phone service though
which we love here on the a3 pokemon
mobile yep
one of the greatest
what is this uh what is this sam or ian
i mean
it's classic jack harlow am i getting a
claim for this [ __ ]
maybe by his high school i don't know
you know jack harlow reminds me of post
malone in a way and he had the kind of
same rise up
this him
this is him
okay but
okay whatever okay
shout out uh that is claimable you know
that's just a song
uh also uh we do have a new button um
for when copyrighted music comes in that
a fan actually created for us would you
like to see it sure no yeah what is it
[Music]
that's cute
the only one that can claim this
ethousie is ela so when i press that
button it kills the audio immediately
from your laptop to uh
yeah that's good music okay fantastic we
love that
thank you to whoever made that for us
who's sam
[Laughter]
somehow
it's just so crazy like to everybody in
the world listening i think it was
obvious
she was talking i thought
because no because they weren't keyed
into the interview like me
because she kept blurring out her
friend's name and not mentioning a
friend so i was like wait is she
mentioning her friend's name because she
kept
not wanting to mention it
and then i thought she was like i talked
about it she's talking about sam and i
was like oh must be her friend
whatever okay
you get it comes with the territory okay
it's a neat
it's an ethan klein moment you get it
what it is
what i did a whole apology sam are you
recovering okay the best apology
i'm getting there i'm getting over it
yeah she's
she's okay we're we're taking care of
her
you know
um i am so excited for saturday though
we got a babysitter
tomorrow
yeah we're gonna drink some beers
have some pizza
what kind of beer do you want we were
talking about we i like coors light i
just keep it light baby drink beer you
want a specific drink
maybe
white wine
or champagne
why
okay
cocktail do you like spear senator
i don't know i'm i'm new to drinking
again you know what we did in like years
okay get some white wine get some
chilled wines
gabe said on the call today that it's
fried chicken saturday so could we get
fried chicken as well maybe oh god maybe
not
you can get whatever you want everybody
it's a grab it's a grab bag everybody
get whatever you want i don't care you
know cam i'll bring my own fried chicken
no i'll buy you fried chicken i i
personally
whenever i eat fried chicken and drink
alcohol my stomach gets absolutely
uh
annihilated not do that again but you're
eating
you're planning on eating a shitload of
pizza tomorrow no no i really put that
out in the world no i'm eating pizza
don't okay nothing will stop me from
eating pizza but the times i remember
when you came home
recently from a podcast when you did
that you felt very nauseous
i felt fine you puked
reward yourself until you're on the
verge of he puked when you guys had a
podcast where you ate a bunch of pizza
and you drank
oh
yeah that one oh you puked up he puked
as soon as he got home well i know you
did i don't remember i remember for you
oh somebody said
jello shots so ela could buy them
can you make those oh yes absolutely i
would love yellow shots okay wait can i
do sugar free jello though yeah oh come
on you want the sugar just cause it's
okay
i can have options oh okay so do the
regular one i thought you'd be excited
about sugar-free jello
regular jell-o
okay
okay player
um
let's see we got so much to get to and
we're not getting to anything um
like what
yeah let's see oh you know i made this
video on ethan klein and about brendan
schaub blocking videos and he released
it so
let's go
let's go
let's go
i don't have to involve the tick tock
lawyer this time
this is something
that
i have never seen yeah but it is
interesting eli you watch this and tell
me what you think this is kind of old
right
yes that's his set when he was yes it
was recorded in december 2019 but i've
never seen it so tell me what you think
oh my god oh my god oh my god
that was the first viral video that that
was the first of our videos
oh dear lord wait who's this kid
that's his editor this logo oh i see why
he's writing his dick
sorry but everybody loved that video the
video we made goofing on logan
don't be acting like you didn't [ __ ]
watch that and love that and just
because you work for him now you know
i've gotta watch it i don't even know
what he said yet well yeah he's an
adorable i'm amazing
and i was new to youtube i didn't know
anything i was just a vine kid and so we
made this colorblind video which i i
i've said this before
i am colorblind but the video was
incredibly embellished
that was the joke
so what's the problem because at the
time he was like yo you're making fun of
my disability bro and it's not cool and
he got super defensive and angry and i
never knew that he actually admitted
that he's embellishing it which was
basically the only the joke that we were
making in the whole video
i think like he's saying he was new and
he didn't know how to handle it
fine but
interesting right yeah thank you
so change the title to logan paul's a
liar okay get right on that no because
our title right now is not that juicy so
we do need something better oh
yeah so yeah logan paul is a dirty
filthy
[ __ ] liar
uh what was his crypto called uh do uh
dink doink dink joint
you're my favorite coin
on my face
i just found the new coin guys
he didn't know what the [ __ ] it was oh
and it was just all classic rug paul
that's why i laugh when people be like
logan's reformed i'm like no he's not he
just pulled a massive scam on his fans
like a year ago
i don't really give a [ __ ] but thanks i
just learned about ding dong
and he did the school a lot of things
like this
yeah
i love them so i'm going to start bro
it's hard to explain okay
yeah he made their theme for them
that's a real song that's a real [ __ ]
song he made
oh my god
i don't know how you missed it well it's
very weird sometimes i catch up almost
everything but then
here's the curved value of dingtong
what is that can you can you verbalize
the value of that for me oh my god
one i'm gonna count the zeros i mean a
one trillionth of a penny or something
five six seven eight nine ten i'm sorry
you like cut you off i got so excited
when i saw
the value of dink doink
can we pull up the dink doing song song
video not so broken though oh you've
never made them yeah yeah yeah yeah no
i'd love to show to you i want to can
you pull up
it's probably on youtube
the dink doink
dink
doink
that is a trillionth of a penny
oh i was right
yeah
so guys that's this is now is the better
time than ever to get in the dink doing
i mean so low that that's kind of
special
[Applause]
you know what in the crypto world these
days it's not that special it's kind of
hard for the course
so yeah logan was like i he pretended
like he just found this even though he's
the creator of it oh god which is proven
by the way wow
like he
and so
and they do a podcast we're like yo what
is this crypto it's awesome wow it's so
cute and funny and they just don't they
don't care that they're a [ __ ]
lotto gambling 100
okay so and then he's like yo i teamed
up with him to make up this video
[Music]
want you to dink on my face take a drink
on my chest yeah yeah dink don't make
you my favorite coin
yeah it was really funny when he sold
all of his shares and was him and mike
were the only ones to make money from it
[Music]
you get the idea it's a good song though
it slaps it kind of
can't really deny it it does
kendrick take notes
it does kind of slap though yeah some
say it slaps the most yeah it slaps the
hardest
it doesn't have a lot of views
i think that's a re-upload i think they
scrubbed the whole
they scrubbed the whole thing you know
what i mean he's on to the next one yeah
now it's a hundred days of uh
of uh
devaluing every day nfts
by the way how did his nfts go
uh well i had a link to it right under
there um
he is oh wait no it's under the uh
the board ape thing that's coming up but
um
here this is where we're at today
this is the epic photo that's being sold
exit my orbit is called
currently has three eighth bid for six
about six thousand so he bur he burned
through all the best ones
yeah we got the board ape out we got the
b ball out we got the mike tyson out
uh i missed this one what's this
oh it's so sick
dude that's so [ __ ] dope
that's such a crazy video
a crazy picture so wait is this one for
sale uh it's sold it sold the other day
how much do we get for it
right now
38 ethereum
38 ethereum no it says three
well this is the this is the resale
market
wait somebody paid 30 80 for that
[ __ ] that's what i'm saying i don't
think this is going to be a massive
failure actually i think the opposite i
think this is a massive success it's
doing really really good
i mean he's already made a lot of money
from it but what's interesting to see is
once we get in the middle of this if
people are still going to be spending
money on this
bro i just don't know
crypto [ __ ] yeah
i just can't believe anyone's buying
this other than people that own like a
steak or something i mean who has that
much etherium laying around that they
would waste it on this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's insane
yeah i i think it's mostly just
teenagers because there's a lot of dumb
teenagers who bought these like nfts
early
and they never sold them i have a friend
from high school who has like 100
or 150 ethereum nft
but how do they how do teenagers get 30
they just cash out then
the thing is if you if you got in early
2018
19 or whatever like
yeah
that stuff went up fast yeah i mean
ethereum used to be worth less than a
hundred dollars and now it's in the
couple thousand range so you're saying
it's just there's a lot of people who
got very
rich by getting in early and you think
they just have all this money they're
around yes it's all new money i i'm
pretty sure it's just doesn't add up to
me because it's it's still like you
could cash out and have real money in
your hand and buy a house if you wanted
they might be sure yeah
but like i don't know i don't understand
it as a community project too it's so
[ __ ] lame because
only super super rich people can
participate
like clearly it's just a money grab
because it doesn't include anyone but
people with a hundred thousand dollars
to waste literally waste
so
like
you know what i mean like it's it's it's
it's honestly it's just a money grab
not computing in my brain i don't
understand it i cannot
i i see these and i'm like i don't get
it i don't understand i
well i think you're right that it
doesn't make sense i think there's like
a cult of people that have convinced
themselves that even in the midst like
you're telling me something
some kids spend eighty thousand dollars
on that
picture
i mean that's still eighty thousand
dollars yeah no it's very real money
yeah like you could buy something in the
real world real money yeah it's just a
loan
no it's real money
some would say the realest this isn't my
first rodeo you're slacking dan some
would say the realest money
some would say that yeah
i trust them
i think you can too
but it's especially interesting and like
one of the biggest
crypto crashes in history
and people are still
buying the ship well look at this
mike malik uh
logan's partner in crime literally and
figuratively tweeted out we're all poor
one day ago and then someone responded
how does that seven hundred thousand
dollar board ape feel now
he says i like i bought it because i
like the artwork
that's what that's
what do you mean he doesn't you what do
you mean he doesn't love this
no what what are you talking about
there's this twitter account crypto bros
taking l's this is where i saw this
this is real right you guys confirmed it
yeah yeah why i bought it because i like
the artwork 700 000 for this [ __ ]
thing bro
no
i [ __ ] my pants today
my brain is refusing
yeah
no
[ __ ] way you said that dude
no
this is the this is [ __ ] hideous this
is dog [ __ ] embarrassing
if you walk if somebody had painted this
in person intricately masterwork uh
spinning image of this and they were
trying to sell this as like physical
original art on the street you wouldn't
[ __ ] look at it for five bucks
maybe five bucks maybe five not over a
hundred i've been seeing a lot of like
murals uh around la of board apes and
it's been
kind of triggering to see that
garbage but you get to drive by it and
see it for free exactly or you can just
right click and save right hold on hey
mike how's 700 thousand dollars feel
got him
oh [ __ ] the police are coming
i just stole his property nope it's
right here what are you gonna do about
it dude
hey [ __ ] look it's my board ape now
it's mine
i'm sorry what was that
yeah
oh that's so funny
so there you have that good times
oh we have the tick tock lawyer calling
in at two something a little bit
let's go dude i'm so excited let's go
let's go let's go
if anybody if any of our audience happen
to make a ton of money on it
and they still have it
get out my personal opinion is a
non-official opinion that you don't have
to listen to i say cash out and go buy a
house
well all these guys got out we had a lot
of ethereum from our little gag we did
we actually got pretty stacked on it and
all you guys exited right because i know
some of y'all were holding i did
everybody i think everyone exited
ian was holding for a long time
i threw that [ __ ] in the stock market
smart
yeah how's that going over the last week
not as bad as crypto stock market will
go back up yeah i know i know that [ __ ]
in the index fund and just let it forget
about that is a far safer
when i made those initially i asked to
be paid in ethereum but you gave me real
money and and he threw me some ethereum
too and i held on to him the ethereum
after the sale and uh put in bitcoin
oh you switched to bitcoin yeah i just
trust bitcoin more but i don't know so
you still have it i do yeah in bitcoin
yeah that was the early ish
so is that also doing bad right now it's
not as bad not as bad as uh whatever the
hell we talked about no no bitcoin is
pretty real
i mean it did drop a lot like let's look
at bitcoin chart
don't look please yeah
why why is you don't want to go it has
been up and down
you know i mean come on it's not it's up
uh through four percent today wait yeah
[ __ ] up even i as a believer in the
technology like don't if you need the
money definitely don't use it as a store
of value it's a dumb investment
if you really believe it in it go for it
if you have money over otherwise cash
the [ __ ] out yeah we have a friend who
told us that she made money and she
bought a house oh yeah we have a friend
who got ethereum like really really
early
or was it bitcoin i don't know just
crypto in general but she was like a
believer back back like on the first
wave
and uh she cashed out and bought herself
a [ __ ] house dude in l.a so shout the
[ __ ] out
yeah
it'd be interesting to see i think
my hunch is at all probably
bitcoin and ethereum i don't know why
people keep holding on to that [ __ ] but
i guess now he's just having a big joke
i mean if you if you go back to the that
bitcoin chart
yeah i'll open it
yeah
you know it's it's gonna get really ugly
uh in the immediate future here but and
a lot of you know these
thousands now of like these stupid
alternative coins like the luna and
everything uh are probably gonna crash
and burn but
i mean bitcoin has been around for well
over a decade like 15 years now or
something 2015
right and it and it goes through this i
mean you see in 2018 that was the last
time there was a huge amount of hype
around crypto and it was like a huge
deal it got as high as it was and look
how insignificant that was compared to
this last giant run and now it's going
to crash again in another five years
it'll happen again it just it goes
through these cycles so
um i i don't really think the bitcoin
is going i agree bitcoin seems pretty
stable
but it's still just musical chairs if
you want to make money you gotta like
be like i'm out i'm in so i'm out
imaginary assets i mean it's it's the
lot it's i mean it's like bro lottery
i also think it's very important to know
what love that i think it's important to
know that even bitcoin and ethereum is
very very much
affected by big hedge funds like most of
the power and money is in big hedge
funds and a very very rich organization
who tank the market
and make people panic sell sheep and
then they buy up more and like juice it
up wait i thought the whole point of
crypto was that exactly that's the point
oh it's the same thing
it's the same thing just like the normal
normal market that's very very because
it's actually i would
it's way more manipulatable i would say
that yeah the stock market has so much
money it takes and it's regulated it's
regulated yeah and there's way more
money in it so it's harder to manipulate
it like that
so like if you have billions of dollars
in liquid assets to throw around yeah
you could you could affect
uh the market
and that's how that's the thing is like
you think that as a normal guy you're
going to come in here
and make all the right trades but the
truth is there's guys with you know 100
billion dollars and they decide when the
market goes up and down so they always
make money
and they probably human trafficking
babies too
because what the [ __ ] i mean who are
these people
you know
but i'm fascinated by it i love it it's
such a roller coaster isn't it
i just
uh it's the most intense roller coaster
it is it is
it really is
what's ethereum doing ethereum price
um
let's see
oh
you know what i'm out [ __ ] all this
[ __ ] i'm getting too deep into it
shout out mike
um
what's the title now logan paul is a no
good liar that's not what i said
i think when you said it you said you
may have used a curse word for emphasis
so i
interpreted that what's a better title
what's like a good angle here
um
oh we got a new tick tock player video
no we've seen this guy
okay so the tick tock layer is coming up
soon
yeah he's actually
in the lobby oh yes okay
so let's just do a quick refresher for
those guys who aren't familiar so
we found this guy panda p firm 2.0 on
tick tock
quickly became one of our favorite
accounts
uh he is a criminal defense attorney and
he just gets basically all the criminals
of gotham out
here's our favorite one it kind of
speaks for itself here all right we're
right outside of van nuys courthouse i
got my great client here he was charged
with a second time dui
uh he admittedly overdosed on multiple
different drugs that night it caused a
drug induced psychosis he crashed with
two other cars on a freeway and flipped
over a few times luckily everyone made
it out all right um the fire department
came with the police used the jaws of
life dragged him out of the car he
started fighting with them they
not five years hell no is normally given
in a second time dui and most
importantly he's really changed his life
around he put himself in rehab good
immediately after this happened he's
been in for night this part's not funny
but he's like
you know this guy
attempted to assassinate the president
uh he missed and killed one of these
secretaries
he was charged for first degree
attempted assassination
we got it reduced to uh time served
and uh probation for a month let's go
let's go it's incredible so
when i uh message him to schedule the
time i was like are you good for two and
he he replied let's go
yeah let's go
let's go so what's his name by the way
david dave david p all right all right
let's have any relation to wally oh
david p let's talk to our boy all right
i'll queue him up right now stand by
david
p
let's
go
all right
oh is this a new one
uh here
he is i'm connecting him right now he
ends every video with let's go david
the legend himself
the lawyer extraordinaire
he doesn't appear to know that i'm here
i think he's connecting his audit david
oh maybe his audio doesn't work
let's go audio david david david says
this to the audio let's go
let's can you hear me oh there we go
what's up
i see two of me oh that ain't right oh
here uh you'll you'll see ethan in just
a second one
so
it's crazy because one is like my side
yeah i don't know it's kind of trippy
uh we'll get you sorted out but david
how you doing how are you my friend you
are a tick tock celebrity
um i'm doing good man honestly the tick
tock's just for fun
i don't know how i feel about celebrity
and all that but uh i just i'm just
happy to be here and i'm happy that
people are having fun with
the work i'm doing
um
am i happy about the haters and and how
they feel
maybe i don't know what who are the
haters what what the haters are a lot of
hate
there are a lot of haters my brother
like a lot of people are out here
commenting my videos
uh a common thing is how would you feel
if one of your loved ones
got killed by a dui driver obviously i'm
a human being i would not like that
but
my job is my job you know what i mean
like you can ask what if
about everything you know like have you
ever had something stolen from you am i
gonna stop representing thieves
well thieves don't usually hire private
counsel so i don't really
represent many of those anyway
well
um let's see
uh
how do you get these people to do the
videos with you afterwards because it
almost seems like a lot of them are like
what is going on like the guy where he
like he flipped his car he fought with
the police he overdosed on a bunch of
drugs you incense psychosis and i'm like
let's go but how do you get someone to
like stand and do that video with you
so ethan it's interesting because i
watched that 20-minute clip of how you
guys were going through my tic-tock
profile and
that was so funny to me man like it was
hilarious and you guys were talking
about it
and uh people
comment a lot saying oh he probably
gives a discount or he probably has it
in the retainer agreement ethan you were
actually right a hundred percent we're
walking right outside the board
and
i just i just say hey there's one thing
we gotta do real quick do you mind if we
take a little video from my social media
and that's it you blindside them right
straight up i mean
they are so happy though yeah
yeah i'm sure they're just stoked
people don't understand they're like oh
why is he putting them on blast i would
never let him do a video like that for
me
those people who are saying that are the
first people to let me do a video for
him because let me tell you
what happens before these videos they're
stressful can we cuss in here yeah you
can say whatever you want all right
they're stressing the [ __ ] out
for the entire time from the moment
they're arrested
from arrest to getting the court
sometimes takes many months
they're freaking out that entire time
they're freaking out as soon as we get
to court
and then that last day they're just they
can't believe
the result we got them and they are so
they love you
yeah they would love to
to
take a video with me
they love it
i've only had one person knock me down
and that's just because i went to law
school with them and they didn't want
like people we both know to figure it
out so so let let me ask you what's the
craziest crime you've got someone off of
oh um
there was a
this was a gang
possession of a concealed loaded firearm
so he was charged
for carrying a concealed firearm
that was loaded
and
also in furtherance of a game
and
uh
i actually had to we actually had a
hearing to suppress the evidence
because on our review of the
initial stop
when the police come and they stop you
they can't stop you willy-nilly they
need to have reasonable suspicion that
you're involved in criminal activity
and
uh
we won that hearing and let me tell you
when i was a prosecutor i have done
probably 40 of those hearings and i
never lost as a prosecutor
and you know i came in at the defense
and i won
and it was really incredible of a
victory
um
i honestly it was on the fence i don't
know if we were going to win or not but
that's probably the craziest one that we
got a full decision
how how um
how much jail time was he looking at
um
i'm not really sure it's probably about
like a year or so oh but that was not
look that wasn't his
main concern his main concern was
because
he
for a living he does he's a security
guard
and he didn't want to lose his ability
to have a gun i see work he was going to
lose his whole career his entire career
and he had kids
so there was a lot on the line for this
case
um
and honestly like i
you know people can hear what i just
said said and say oh this guy just got
like a gang member off or whatever
his conduct was so minimal in that case
he wasn't really a threat to anybody
they were shooting a music video
and it was just a bunch of people who
are in a gang shooting this music video
[Music]
you know
no harm in that right
let's go
let's go yeah let's go
you've been saying that for a while how
did that make it into uh do you say that
when you went in court like how what's
the application of that
let's go your honor
ethan i've been making these videos for
years
pre-covet also and i've just been
posting them on my instagram sometimes
facebook wait there's more of these
yeah wait where do we find more because
i've watched all of them and i was
desperate for more content
on my instagram
now
on tick tock i only started posting on
tick tock because
me and my partner decided that hey you
know what let's just get away from the
criminal practice
we're doing a lot of elder abuse cases
these days that's good that's a worthy
cause nursing homes those are complex
litigation cases
uh and they're very serious
so we kind of wanted to shy away from
the criminal
so i started posting the videos
uh
my my criminal defense videos on tick
tock just because i didn't have anywhere
else to post them and i was still making
new ones because i still have criminal
cases
and it exploded
but i've been saying let's go for years
i've been saying hey we're right outside
of court with my great client for years
do you ever consider making merch
no someone it's interesting you said
that somebody mentioned that to me the
other night and i quickly dismissed it
no we need let's go emergency
i'm not really like trying to
go viral or anything um but i think it'd
be cool to have some hats that say let's
go or something can i ask you a question
it's someone i know this happened to and
you tell me if you could get this person
off okay
go for it
so he had he's had a previous dui
this is his second time driving drunk
and he hits and runs a police car
while drunk already has a previous dui
gets arrested
and what happened to him is that it got
reduced to a wet and reckless do you
think that you could do that or is that
like kind of insane
to get i think i could do that and the
reason why what really puts this guy in
a good position to beat the dui charge
and or have it reduced to a reckless
is because he hit and rent
now
hit and run is another crime you're
saying hit and run is a good thing in
this case
i love you dude you're the [ __ ] goat
bro so are you suggesting that people
hit and run if they're drunk
what are you suggesting that if you're
drunk you hit and run i don't suggest it
but it could help
disclaimer dui is extremely dangerous
crime is very very bad now okay but
let's say
let's say you just freak out and you
happen to have hit and run because
you're sure okay
sure
they need to prove beyond a reasonable
doubt that you were intoxicated you're
impaired by alcohol or at 0.08
blood alcohol content or higher at the
time of driving
it becomes very hard for the prosecutors
to do that
if
at the time you're driving you know you
hit the car and then you ran away and
now let's say it's like an hour two or
three or four later they come up to you
what's stopping you from saying look i
just needed a drink after that that was
hectic oh my god
[Laughter]
that's probably what he did of course
i'm talking about ryan kavanagh
good friend of the show
we were wondering how someone with the
previous dui hit and run a police
officer while drunk and gets reduced to
wet reckless but i think that's a really
i think that's a really good insight to
what happened to ryan kavanagh
yeah but ryan
gets [ __ ] because he crashed into a
cop car and hit and run and if you do a
hit and run and
causing injury and the injury could just
be like my neck hurts
he's in california at least you're
losing your license for an entire year
that actually might happen have happened
because he has a driver now i don't
think he's allowed to drive
but i like that so guys
you heard it here if you get if you're
drunk and you are in a collision
get the hell out of there right
so i am not going to save money
i i actually suggest
nothing like look like
you do what you do okay call me after
you've done what you've done
i'll i can play
uh look i just play the cards on delves
but i will never tell anyone commit a
crime or anything all primes let's go
but i'll tell you um
whenever i get a call i just got this
girl called me like last week and she
said hey i freaked out and i ran away
and then the cops came to my house and i
said okay little
stop tripping out right
it was bad that you ran away but it kind
of helped you with the dui
my boy let's go
let's go right now
you're pretty slick uh do you consider
what do you think about the comparison
of you to uh sal goodman for example
i love saul goodman i love that show
you like the way he does law
i don't think he does it
ethically i can't it's been a while
since i watched the show
um and i remember watching the first
seasons when i opened up my own office
and i really felt him because he was
down he was like at rock bottom he
wasn't making any money and neither was
i
and as lawyers there are a lot of rules
of ethics we have to follow
with every regard and especially when
you're trying to get new clients and i
think he was
committing some epic violations or
something like that which i understand
when you're
in a tough place like you just kind of
want to say [ __ ] it let's make some
money
um but you know i think it was funny and
i liked that he was a criminal lawyer i
wish he did more
practice of law i don't think he ever
tried a case
in that show
i don't remember he was involved in that
big elder abuse there's a lot of
parallels my friend
you might just be the real lifestyle
goodman
you know how the nursing home in that
kit in that show was ripping off the
elderly overcharging them
um right
yeah what i do is usually it's kind of
more medical malpractice-y where the
nursing homes
uh
under staff themselves to save money
and now all these old people are being
neglected they fall they break bones
they gotta get surgeries or they develop
pressure sores where it's like their
body their flesh eats away at themselves
to the bone sometimes because they're
not being rotated enough when they're
paralyzed they're not mobile it's gnarly
my friend it's really gnarly but
you know
someone's gotta help so how's business
now are you doing well money's good
uh thank god we're doing great yeah
thank you like it's you know it's just a
blessing you know we really started with
nothing here
who's we it's you and a partner yeah so
my partner we started he was a
prosecutor with me
and
uh it wasn't for us
i don't think we were look i dreamt of
being a prosecutor i wanted to be a
prosecutor for a long time
and after being in it and taking every
case i could to jury trial
uh
you know we just felt like you know what
we weren't really destined for this
uh i think that our talents are better
used
actually on the private sector we can
actually help people as a prosecutor you
don't have a client
you have this fictional thing where you
say hey i represent the people of the
state of california
and then the jurors look at you like you
just wasted two weeks of my time for
this like
he said she said case
you kidding me
so um
well
listen i think you're a brilliant league
uh legal mind
clearly
you're one someone say the brightest
what's your instagram because i want to
make sure we get to view all of your
content i don't want to miss a single
video
it's p
and p
firm okay
is pnp firm 2.0
what happened to 1.0
well pnp firm got deleted it got banned
from tick tock
i was so confused i had no idea why
and i appealed it and they told us that
yeah you violated our violent extremism
policy
weird maybe when your clients did but
yeah i mean they probably did but i'm
i'm just practicing law you know they're
they're statutes and like this is all
legal this is totally all legal
i guess tick tock doesn't approve of uh
the clients you represent but you know
what
that's ridiculous isn't it
it is i think that can i ask you a
question working at tick tock
who's just like [ __ ] this guy
let me ask you a question
have you ever got someone off or you're
like
maybe that guy should be in jail
never
not i don't believe you
not even close
um
there have been times where
honestly people have been in jail and i
just wish that they could have gotten
help instead
that's true that's true i think that
uh
look we need to send people to jail we
do like i'm sorry but it has to be done
a lot of the time just to keep society
safe
jail is not like there's a lot of people
who say like defund the police you can
feel the way you want we do need these
people they're really saving us from
tiering like it's
but wait is it saving us from tyranny
uh
saving us not from tier from from just
chaos okay okay yeah sorry okay
there
there are alternatives to jail there's
rehab
there's
you know outpatient rehabs are great
uh
you know you can make someone do a ton
of labor
where they go pick up trash on the
freeway and if they don't do it then
they can go to jail
you can really punish people without
sending them to jail
come on brother i'm right there with you
what i said i'm right there with you i
agree yeah a lot of people comment my
video saying no send them back
back where like send them to jail they
should go to prison for this dui
okay well if you send people to jail
like oh you did you committed a dui or a
drug or alcohol substance abuse related
offense okay yeah let's send you to jail
what happens when you send this person
they come out
and they go right back to doing what
they were doing right
most likely what if you sent them to
rehab and you gave them a little love
and you encouragement to really turn
their lives around
wouldn't that be better for society you
got to prevent you need to be
preventative
and not
punitive exactly let's go
yeah let's go brother so i have my own
personal philosophy of how i practice
criminal defense
um
whenever i get a client i just try to
work with them see how their life is why
this happened
or do they have a drinking problem
uh
a lot of my clients i get them into aaa
right away
and
i and i talk to them about how they feel
about their lives and i counsel them
like i've had a lot of addiction in my
family i've had like some issues myself
i've been to these meetings a lot
uh
so
i've seen the work i've done on people's
lives some people are not receptive to
it
i've had really sad times where i've
worked really hard with the client and
then they just relapse and screw their
whole case up and
you know i've had to go my separate ways
from some people
but i'll tell you each one of my clients
that i've gone all the way for and
each one of my clients i've posted a
video for
has really worked on themselves and they
really deserve the result that we got
that's nice
that's actually really nice to hear
well there you go you really are doing a
public service you keeping the people
out let's get them better and let's get
them going
let's go let's go
i'm going to call you next time i need
legal advice or legal analysis okay
i'm always there for you guys what's
your hourly rate in case anyone's
looking for a uh criminal defense
attorney
well in criminal law we don't charge
hourly it's all flat fee uh really you
just tell me i'll i'll give anyone a
free consultation
and i already know what work is going to
have to go into representing this a
philosophy what the hell dude i'm paying
my lawyers some crazy hourly [ __ ] bro do
you know anything about do you know
anything about uh intellectual property
or copyright
i don't practice that kind of law you
can learn it come on let's go let's go
all right for sure let's go
no i'm just kidding
i'm just kidding our lawyers are doing
good yeah they're doing it you're yeah
you're you guys probably got some good
lawyers
well we're being sued by ryan cavanaugh
and it's a complicated copyright ip
stuff but i like the idea of that flat
rate what do you wh
let's talk flat rate maybe i can
negotiate with my
attorneys
yeah yeah and use it as leverage
yeah i mean like look a first-time dui
where the courthouse is near my office
and it's nothing special no enhancements
no prior duis
like i'll charge like five grand for you
okay
easy
it gets more the more duis you have or
more enhancements or if it's a more
serious crime what's an environment
what what's an enhancement
so for example
if you commit a dui
you get charged with dui but let's say
now
when you were caught your blood alcohol
content was at
0.15
or greater so you're at almost double
the legal limit if you're double the
legal limit or higher okay
they're going to charge you a dui
and with an enhancement for having your
blood alcohol content so high while you
were dealing with it i see it and that
way you'll let them give your client
enhanced penalties i see or if you're
speeding
on the freeway 30 miles per hour or
higher um or on a normal street 20 miles
per hour or higher that's mandatory 60
days minimum jail time i see i see
or if you refuse the blood alcohol test
that's an enhancement
what's that oh a mandatory
do you recommend if somebody gets pulled
over
and let's say they had a couple of
drinks should you always refuse the the
blower
i i would say so refuse the it's the
preliminary alcohol screening device
that's what we actually call it or the
breathalyzer at the scene where you get
pulled over that's optional refuse it
because look the crime
the crime ended as soon as you're pulled
over because now you're no longer
driving
it's driving while impaired or driving
while
0.08 or higher
so as soon as you're pulled over the
crime is is over and now they have to
prove that before you were pulled over
you were impaired
you're giving them evidence
of what your blood alcohol content was
right at the time of driving when you
agreed to do that optional test
it sucks
now imagine if you refuse that one
[Music]
and you go to the station and it maybe
takes an hour two
three
to take the mandatory one
then you're you've burnt some alcohol
probably you can help out sure
yeah you can refuse and then go do a
blood test really
i've had cases dismissed
because it's taken longer than three
hours
to do the mandatory blood test
the or breath test
and that's because the toxicologists
cannot reverse extrapolate what your
blood alcohol content could have been at
the time of driving if it's been more
than three hours wow so that's kind of
faulty well there you go that's actually
good advice to all my drunk drivers out
there
the best advice
but um let's see the other one is hit
and run if you're drunk so that was a
good also so we're learning a lot so hit
and run avoid the blower and the other
one is um
what other kind of like basic
legal recommendations you have because
actually i love i think it's really
interesting to get an insight from
someone like you that deals with kind of
like these
petty cr you do mostly do like small
petty crimes right you're not
you don't represent like violent
criminals do you
not anymore because honestly i'm just so
busy with the complex litigation
that
uh that's why we just wanted to stop
taking criminal cases all together
um but what other advices do you have
why or a domestic violence case because
because i've really done so many of them
so it's kind of just so if you're
beating up your partner do you have any
advice to how not to get caught i'm just
kidding guys just kidding um well i have
a lot of advice okay domestic violence
but yeah what would you want to know i
mean it's
here's
here's how it is
okay there's there's different kinds of
domestic violence but
either there are injuries or there are
no injuries okay either they're gonna
charge you with domestic violence
causing an injury and usually it's
bruising or if like someone's choking
someone you're gonna have redness around
the neck
or it's just domestic battery where it's
like someone got pushed or slapped or
like splashed water on someone
uh so
if it's domestic battery
it's kind of he said she said
don't admit to anything that's my number
one advice
uh you don't even have to run away or
anything just don't talk to the police
everyone says that but you have no idea
how many people are guilty because they
just start talking
or here's my number one advice
don't think you're smart
don't think that oh i'm gonna outsmart
the cops oh yeah she did this or he did
this like no just seriously just shut
the [ __ ] up
you're never gonna be smarter at that
point than you would have been if you
shut up waited to get the police report
in court and then you can plan on what
you want to say after you already have
been shown their cards which is your
right
is this is this true of someone on
either side of the uh domestic abuse
thing like if you're the victim what
what should you do to get justice on
someone
um well
the victims believe it or not a lot of
the time they
don't want
their spouse or boyfriend girlfriend to
be prosecuted right a lot of the time
their interest is
i feel bad for getting the police
involved
you know i
i understand it do i agree with it not
really because
domestic violence is kind of like a if
someone commits db
they're gonna they're likely to do it
again it's a character trait because
it's counterintuitive why would you ever
harm your spouse
like why would you ever punch
your wife in the face like that's not
something people
are usually do but if you're the type of
person that does that
and you're angry again tomorrow you're
likely to do it again right so people
are wired a certain way
and the law recognizes that your next
domestic violence case they can bring up
the fact that you're convicted before to
show that you have a propensity to do
this again right you can't do that with
a lot of other crimes you can do that
with domestic violence you can do that
with sex crimes
but not really anything else
if you are the victim and you really
want this person to go down
uh it's tough i mean like save photos of
your bruises
you know cooperate with the police
but
know that if you're going to start
testifying like all angry and upset at
this person for hitting you
you're going to lose a little bit of
credibility
and it's going to show that you know
they're really angry at this person
maybe they just made this up
just be cool
just you know be sincere and don't go
over the top
because as a defense attorney i would
use the anger against a victim of course
that's what i mean that's my job
exactly it's not practice not to
that's true so you're usually defending
the uh of course the the violent uh
the
violent person yeah let's go
yeah i mean all right
we can get a good result
i don't i don't
i don't like that they do it but the
thing is when they come to me it's
already done
it's already done
someone's got to do it right somebody's
got to do it
you're not going ahead you have a
headline the victim be the one you
represent though
i represented victims before um
and i've had situations where both
parties just eat the [ __ ] out of each
other
i've had i've had a situation where a
a
you know
cute skinny girl stabbed her boyfriend
with the scissors and he went to the
police and we got that
we got that rejected from filing which
is a dismissal before the case is even
fired were you rejecting the cute skinny
girl that stabbed them
or were you wrapping i mean
we too i took her on as a client yeah
you were representing the cute skinny
girl that stabbed your boyfriend let's
go
yes
yeah and you got that thrown out
awesome dude so how'd you do that
um
well he really didn't want her to be
prosecuted okay so that helps
it helps
so
to sum it up
uh you know i
he called me and i told him look you go
get your own attorney and have that
attorney clone
which he did
so
i believe
that his attorney and i'm being trying
to be very careful not to disclose
certain things but
his attorney advised him to plead the
fit
to the police because the police are
going to call him for follow-up
um
so this is what happens this is a
timeline of a domestic violence
investigation
the domestic violence happens one person
calls the police the police come make
their arrest write down a report the
report then goes to a detective at the
police station the detective a few days
later or a week later or two weeks later
calls the victim back and gets
interviews them again and tries to get
them to confirm everything they said
on that first day
the reason they do that is because they
want to make sure that this person
wasn't just angry and making this stuff
up
uh when they called the police so a
victim
is a lot more believable
if when they're
calm and cool and collective says the
same story
because i'm telling you a lot of the
time in these cases
they
[Music]
when you get to court and then you get
to trial
they say you know what i'm sorry i'm
actually at fault here you know i'm the
one that was attacking them and i made
this all up that's called a recanting
victim
and
so they want to they want to make it so
that if this victim recants later on
they will have no credibility because
look you were consistent this entire
time
and now you're changing your story so do
you think that she's gonna stab again or
you think it was a one-time
stab i think it's a one-time stab yeah
okay that's guys
yeah well um yeah that's good that's
good we'd like yeah i mean
i mean no one should have done that but
like
also he was acting a little up so he
deserved it in a way i don't think he
deserved it but
it wasn't
you know
it wasn't as egregious as i've seen
again
let's go
well anyway
i love it oh is it so basically your
advice is don't talk to the cops in any
situation refuse the blood test
if you commit a crime run from the scene
we're all good right so here let me give
you a disclaimer ethan
nothing i have said in this podcast is
legal advice oh okay but
it is
they are things that i have seen and i
have seen when when these certain things
happen the way i've described the
results were much better than others in
the cases i have there you have it
well if you guys if you guys are
stabbing your partner getting into
drunken runs or you have a nana who's
being abused
your boy right here david is the man
right i mean he's the guy so give him a
call do you want to plug anything
what do you mean like uh your tick tock
your instagram or your law firm
i don't know if it's is it illegal for
you to say call me
um
i don't think so but you know honestly
ethan i never did any of this for
marketing it's just fun yeah and i grew
up wanting to be a stand-up comedian
i like i like doing things that are
funny
i'm just having fun you know i'm not
really
out here looking for more clients i have
enough clients god bless like all right
like things have been great so don't
call me but uh if anyone wants my advice
and you live in southern california
or anything yeah feel free to reach out
to us you can find our instagram p and p
firm
you know feel free to dm us or reach out
i'd love to help anyone i i give free
consultations all the time i love
helping people there you have it
david how do i pronounce your last name
it's porcelain or shalimi wait is that
it doesn't mean anything we're jews from
iran so like
it was
that we had to assimilate so they
wouldn't know interesting okay well
shout out uh we're jews as well so big
ethan i got a quick question of you guys
so
i never watched your beautiful podcast
until the clip that i saw you guys going
through my tip talk
so i figured you know what i got i got
to do a little research and i went on
wikipedia
and i saw that you guys uh met on your
birthright trip yeah
that's right and uh at yad vashem the
holocaust that's right
i'm gonna keep that in mind next time i
go there i'm gonna look for look for
someone nice there to me
right yeah no people don't expect it but
it's the best place to pick up chick you
know they're sad they're mourning
they're vulnerable
these red pill guys could take a tip
from me i tell you what
yeah i see you yeah let's
let's
go
let's go all right thanks for calling
david you take care thanks for sharing
great to hear from you and uh
you know when one of us get uh when you
know get into trouble we're gonna call
you first okay god forbid but i'm always
there for you yeah thank you so much for
having me on all right thank you all
right bye thank you david
what a legend
let's go that guy's a [ __ ] let's go
let's go
i'll tell you what if i got a dui for
whatever reason i'm calling david
he's like yo dude i love the advice that
you have to
you should ex you should [ __ ] bail
dude
like ryan did you [ __ ] you should
bail from the scene so they think [ __ ]
it oh [ __ ] it
dude you got home and started drinking
it's genius
it's so sal goodman isn't it
too much sorry yes speaking wish did you
see this uh edit that cam just threw
together no let's let's make the
disclaimer that
better dial david yes
give the disclaimer okay
you should not drink and drive that is
serious
serious
trouble
because not only are you trying to avoid
trouble for yourself you don't want to
end up hurting someone else
so just don't drink and drive right
thank you right right you should never
hate someone violence is not
advantageous what about stab with the
scissor you shouldn't don't stop people
with scissors either okay let's go yeah
i and you know what for the most part it
looked like the audience was enjoying
this i did see some people that were
uncomfortable with this and i understand
you got to keep in mind
you know it is a good thing that defense
lawyers exist and you know it can be
uncomfortable at times but you it is
your constitutional right to have
representation
and
you know a lot of people are accused of
crimes that uh falsely or that they
didn't commit or you know will suffer a
consequence from that accusation
that like he was alluding to you know
the consequence far exceeds
uh
you know proportionally what uh damage
was done to society
and so
you know
[Music]
they deserve the best representation
actually he won me over when he was like
these people who i represent really have
made an effort to rehabilitate
themselves and going to prison is not
going to help it's not going to help
anyone you know
prison is really the worst way to
rehabilitate anybody
let's be honest so let's go you know i
love that though the girl stabbed her
boyfriend he's like yo we got that [ __ ]
thrown out before it even reached the
[ __ ]
clerk
let's oh legend
love that man
by the way what i nailed it he said he
just blindsides him
and he straight up admit that he's like
yeah i just blindfolded the funniest
part by
you were right you were right i really
was leaning towards it being like i'll
give you 10 off if you do this video
with me but no it's just hey hold on a
second i'm just gonna take this video
real quick you just start listing off
all their horrible crimes they're like
what is happening
yo by the way we gotta comb through his
instagram for other bangers
yeah yeah definitely
so
let's put that in a future episode but
yeah
i think i got their question answered
there at the end the whole time they
were wondering if he was single
he had a ring on didn't he no he's
single you all were first thing for
david yeah there was a lot
of all the time he's very handsome i
mean he's a lawyer he's got a good job
but uh based on that comment at the end
i think he's single
oh right because he alluded to he was
inspired
ladies
okay we got some bachelor david or
bachelor dad
bachelor david would be [ __ ] awesome
dude i'm here for that [ __ ] don't make
me i'm i'm gonna pull the clip
when you're said
the bachelor is over forever
and it's over it is over
it still is over i'm just i think we
just like to look for the ideal next
bachelor sure nothing ever happens with
it though right i think someday we might
find the perfect candidate and bring it
back
but again it's just too much liability
for us like
you know that's the i'm just saying if
we set someone up and it's a match from
hell yeah something terrible happens you
know everyone's going to blame me
exactly
even though sam and ian true love will
find you in the end
thank you you guys should be thanking me
because of my feet every day
tristan moses on the other hand
[Music]
good timing
i was saying trisha on mo
[Music]
all right i get the idea you guys are
gonna let me speak my mind
because trisha moses
all right i'll stop doing that
[Music]
all right
um
who's in charge of that is it then
oriented both ian and i have the ball
that was me doing it that time that's
good that's good
eli should get the power too
by the way so
yes our last episode
on wednesday
we had a pretty explosive interview
with a very nice young lady smart
eloquent
who told a story about how
fit from fresh and fit
uh she doesn't want to characterize it
as
essay
so out of respect i won't say that
but let's just say had a really really
really really really really really bad
time with fit yes
and they're preparing a response
here it is of course it's got me in a
diaper
you know which is basically you can
pretty much count on that any time
anyone has anything to say about me
[Music]
what do you guys think about that diaper
fit is it a total dunk
it's a dunk in their world
it's me in a diaper they got me
i mean they
yeah this dude's never had a girlfriend
and i don't mean and i'm not trying to
as you say that no one has rose as a
loser but this guy whole life is about
dating and this [ __ ] never dated
that makes him a [ __ ] loser
[ __ ] loser and by what a beta he is
this homie who we were goof on is the
one that owns the whole show
fresh is the brains and the money oh
really yeah this guy's a broke idiot
this is the guy that he actually made
all the money she's thought she taught
us walter oh
yeah some barbados
[ __ ] coconuts and barbados
hey walter there's got to be better
people to give you dating advice like to
look up to how about people that
actually have been in a relationship
before
to start me talk to me bro
so anyway it says false allegations
when believe all women goes wrong
accusations debunk with facts and
evidence they put the clown emoji on her
yeah i noticed that classy
the other thing is um
they needed a long time to prepare this
it's not even going live till tonight
it's like bro you guys getting your
story straight or what oh wait they
already recorded it we have a trailer
no i think they were just uh
hyping it i guess they went in the
studio with girls well they had an
episode yesterday
oh oh okay so it's from that yeah yeah
apparently they've been deleting
comments like crazy look at the side
hey how dare you how dare you censor
bloated corpse
that's her username
so let me see this let me catch this
trailer
11 pages
shout out death noodles pages 11 pages
uh fresh and fit pockets say they are
being me tooed with lots of
i think first of all you have to
have some clout and relevance to be me
too
you're not being me too bro somebody
just said you
she had a bad day i mean but okay so
guys we're going to go ahead and address
the the [ __ ] allegations that came
in as you all know um
ethan let a girl call into the show that
had been on the podcast before she said
a whole bunch of [ __ ] lies yeah
all that stuff from man
her biggest mistake is she doesn't
realize what the [ __ ]
did they say he's the best
i love him he's so he's just adds so
much to the show yeah can we see that
again he goes that isn't my mommy he's
like boomhauer i don't date a minute
i'll tell you what man
you need to watch that again with
pleasure
did you see the part where we found out
he's a fed
a fed yes
[ __ ] this guy's a fed who worked on
the human trafficking department and
he's [ __ ] friends with human
traffickers yeah
thanks
what's the what's his relation to the
other guy they're just friends
yeah he's been on a bunch of times and
they love his abs
they build him up like you know
anyway here it is why y'all are here so
guys we're going to go ahead and address
the the [ __ ] allegations that came
in as you all know um
ethan let a girl call into the show that
had been on the podcast before she said
a whole bunch of [ __ ] lies yeah
all that stuff from man
her biggest
what the [ __ ] was that i i understand
you said i don't know where she got all
that stuff from but the second part
it's like you're on a podcast bro you
can't even speak
you're doing a show where you speak and
you can't speak
this mistake is she doesn't realize that
and i'll tell you how this there's a
reason she has so the text messages
there's a reason why she was very
ambiguous to what she did and there's a
reason why she sent screenshots versus
the entire conversation so i got all
that stuff because i always keep
receipts and then also
listen if you weren't doing what you're
doing i wouldn't be so paranoid about
keeping all the receipts you know do you
know what i'm saying yeah you'd be like
yo i better after that encounter i
better save all the correspondence in
she's
in case she talks about this
also how do you share somebody a text
message conversation other than screen
shotting it i don't really well he was
like he expected us to read the totality
of all of their texts or something how
i guess she she would have to screenshot
it is that i don't yeah i just don't
know i think what he meant was that
there was missing context or something
yeah okay
by the way which is why she's so brave
for sharing because the obvious
uh response was going to be this so
i can't get over the boomhauer come on
now man coconuts from barbados this is
wednesday boomer bobby
every single thing she lied about so
i was meticulous about this man she's
about to take a big fat [ __ ] l
because i'll tell y'all this right now
you can't meet too marin baby you can't
you might take this l so uh what's up
i'm sure
i don't know how you're gonna disprove
that you jumped on her in bed
but okay and i mean i saw her text
message to her friend
where she was like scared
and said she was crying and stuff but
okay dude
right and she forgets that like i was in
person so i actually know what happened
versus what you said because yeah you're
in on it why the [ __ ] would i believe
you dumbass
you helped separate the friends you
[ __ ] loser obviously you're gonna put
it in like to make yourself look good
but yo you captain yeah make this
announcement right
i love him
we got the proof we got the pictures all
that [ __ ] hey oh we got witnesses too by
the way so you're really about to look
stupid
tomorrow
so when you guys all i gotta say is this
we learned from witnesses you were in
the apartment just the two of you
who witnessed that
meg right the stallion and we learned
from amber turd you can't believe all
[ __ ] women and h3 is about to take
another l because y'all go ahead and
bring this clown chaser on your show let
us say a bunch of [ __ ] five months
after the fact thinking we don't got
receipts and they're reaching man oh
lord you bout to look stupid tomorrow
bro so
we got the text
unless you have like a camera in your
apartment
[Laughter]
in every room
how about 11 pages of handwriting
i got 11 [ __ ] pages y'all about to
look dumb as hell
my guess for his evidence is just gonna
be that it's like
text where she's being nice to him
where she's being like somewhat
receptive and saying like let's hang out
or something well i mean she said as
much in the conversation yeah i mean
that was the whole thing
i think that's it he's gonna be like
look she said she wanted to hang out
look she was being nice to me here she's
obviously you know i think that'll
that's basically all he's got i guess
we'll see
17
pages
dude spends his all this time with women
and he can't get a girlfriend how
[ __ ] sick are you
you can't get any girl to date you
because you're so repulsive that's nuts
wednesday
it is bro man it is wednesday [ __ ]
anyway so that's i guess
obviously i don't recommend watching the
show
because i don't want to give them views
but uh
if anything interesting comes out of it
we'll report on it obviously
thank you
um
so
ace family by the way
final the ace family's house finally
sold
it was actually finally sold
for nine million dollars
to two more youtubers
man it takes a [ __ ] sucker to move
into that house bro idiot these two
goons team 10 of team 10 fame
i don't know how these kid boppers make
so much money but there it is they
bought it for 9 million bucks it was
valued at
i think they got like a pretty fat
discount the original price was 13
million just under 13 million yeah but i
think it's probably worth more like nine
because considering nothing in the house
is
do you guys know what you're getting
yourself into
why like that house was a [ __ ]
junkyard
they literally tore the
appliances out
but okay
young money dumb money good luck guys
shout out to the stoke brothers
the stoke twins i gotta say there's
something about young girls and they
[ __ ] love these twins there's so many
popular twins like twin boys
is that a fantasy
where they just want to get like double
teamed by these twins or something
i don't know
y'all fantasize about getting double
teamed by a twin i mean what's happening
why these twins everywhere
do you remember when we talked about
them that one time um they were doing
the uh bank robbery oh my god i forgot
yeah it's in the dark
a little these guys they were doing a
big bank robbery 25 and i wanted to
bring that up i look so young
like you're you're 25 you're extremely
successful at a young age you have tons
of money yeah
uh you buy a house jointly with your
brother
bro no they they ride together die
together
are they making content together i guess
if they're just planning on doing
content there no but i don't think about
that i mean they're 25 time to move out
get your own house i don't want to live
with my brother at 25. they love the sex
appeals the two of them
that's what people want it's what people
demand the only thing i can think of is
that it's they're gonna make their
content there and they like if i don't
know anything about their contact
content but if they shoot together then
maybe it's like part of the appeal for
them
of living together yeah they're one of
these dude these guys sleep in the same
bed i mean come on
no they don't even how do you know that
they don't because they have bunk beds
right
that's fair dan's gonna come
so i don't know if you remember this
either but they did this bank robbery
prank
where the police kept calling out they
did like a fake bank robbery
that really scared people it's such a
[ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] [ __ ] prank yeah
like
the worst of the worst of youtube
pranksters that scared me
okay shoot okay i'm kind of in a pickle
right now crap okay all right well thank
you
security guards i can like provide you
guys they got bitched out by the police
and then they've like made a
ending where they're like well [ __ ] that
isn't that what happened i don't
remember uber driver i got arrested and
everything i believe they eventually got
the uh
they actually hired david got all
charges dismissed
let's go let's go
um no such thing as a coincidence ethan
uh a solid third of our audience wants
to be double teamed by twins
okay well
no it's 66 but 34 is a lot it's a lot
it's the third
third of the chat double teamed
i think our demos i don't know but
there's something about twins because
they're so popular if you notice that i
mean ethan i think you're
overlooking a big fat it's not just that
they're twins they're good looking yeah
they're hot they're hot twins it's just
i mean and that isn't yeah i mean that's
twins novel really i mean
i feel like maybe this has died out but
like that used to be like a trope in
media all the time of like with guys and
like twins and they're twins like two
hot blondies no i've heard that i just
so it's just it's the flip version of
that
but it's real
uh i think it's real that people
fantasized about twins too like men
fantasizing that women let's go ladies
we got two hot little twins here for
your pleasure and they've got a big old
mansion and one bed
seriously thought they look like 15 yeah
they look super young thank you so much
man wow because you guys are pulling up
so i called the emergency non-emergency
number about like um i think the other
day
this was on the other day saturday and i
told them that we'll be filming saturday
and on wednesday as well this is what's
this [ __ ] idiot i called the
non-emergency number i told him we'd be
filming [ __ ] you're in la that's not
how you get a permit [ __ ] ass i'm gonna
get someone potentially gun stuck or
something
what that we have people stopping in the
middle of street because they're
watching this
guy's pulling up ski masks throwing
stuff on the ground changing clothes
is kind of like
does this guy look familiar
is that the guy who was on impulsive
who was talking [ __ ] about me
oh the editor
no
okay that would have been wild
mary too you think about what's going on
nowadays think about it man you've got
to be smarter than that man you know
better
i love that they included them getting
absolutely [ __ ] grinded on by the
police and they still uploaded it like
dumbass too all these twins i think when
you're a hot twin your brain power gets
divided by two because they are dumb as
[ __ ] like every pair of them is dumber
than the next i want you guys to be
creative and do what you want to do but
you've got to be smarter
what do you think people are going to do
you know what cop just shoot him
just shoot him say he tried to attack
yourself i love that you got to be
smarter than this
it's like a student being yelled at by a
teacher
it's it's just going one out the other
side of this year you're absolutely
all right just be careful
yeah i think that's a good idea
if you rent a facility you're in a wide
open parking lot you set it up you worry
everything's locked up and poor enough
everybody in that scene
knows you're doing this you do your
thing nobody gets called because it's in
a closed controlled environment okay
you're not gonna have public people
walking by going what the hell
9-1-1 we've got guys with ski masks
you get your uber driver pulled over too
and he's freaking out
it's awesome right
so there you go congratulations to these
two dumb [ __ ]
nice
we're moving it to the ace family uh i
wonder how inspections went on that
house
it's probably
well because it was foreclosed on and
owned by the bank and [ __ ] i just
yeah they probably did have inspections
you're right and it i'm sure it went
horribly
that's a big project for a couple of
bozos
do you think they're gonna ride jet skis
in the pool
you know what
they'll probably ride two jet skis
because they're twins
let's see i can't wait to see i'll be
following closely yeah this is
challenging hello this is hello
oh they're huge on tick tock they have
30 million followers
wow
here's what kind of content they make on
tick tock
what do you guys want uh let me get a
frate
what do you guys want uh let me get a
fratte mo
that uh let me get a trenta pinkity
drinky
frankity piggity
oh it keeps changing
apparently
apparently that is their dad uh
wait so do they shoot anything at the
house because what is the reason to
living together
that's the joke eh
yeah no it doesn't look like it looks
like they're out and about quite a bit i
mean here's one of the houses
he's just posting a video
that was fake that wasn't even real
oh my god bro stop it right now
it's funny
that has four million
oh no it's one of these hold on let me
go back i wanna watch this
wait wait god damn it
what
it keeps every time i [ __ ] flip my
finger it goes to a new video you see it
like what the [ __ ] tick tock you [ __ ]
here it is
i'm just trying to zoom
well don't
as as
wait they both stole from each other
what the [ __ ] is happening oh it keeps
going
he stole his girl dude no way what a
[ __ ] no way
okay
wait here's another one let's see this
took the back
[Music]
he helps him out
chases down the thief
uh
he gets him
gets the bag wait they're huge on
youtube no they're yeah they just bought
a nine million dollar house
and he throws it away
okay
yep
yeah they're huge on youtube okay so i
guess they are they are killing it
congrats to the stoke brothers
congratulations
oh you know what we've been wanting to
do uh we need to talk about how apple
has discontinued the ipod after 21 years
it's finally over
oh no and rip the ipod was first
introduced by steve jobs in 2001
and never owned one i didn't either but
it was a big deal at the time yeah
did any of you guys have one that was
like the first way to digitally hold
music right yeah well there were first
one there were other like
shittier versions yeah but it definitely
popularized mp3 players yeah i don't
know if some of you are probably too
young but
it was like a tiny little thing with
just one little wheel on it
it's like a little box i don't know i
always found it's kind of weird
but maybe i just wasn't up with the tech
at the time
i mean it worked well enough
but it was a big deal we had we didn't
know any better no touch screens my
first one was the ipod um
mini which was the first time that's the
one i'm talking about yeah they
introduced colors
i had a green one i had an ipod nano it
was only one gig
wait a nano yeah
they were like a really tiny little yeah
and i loved it it was my savior on the
school bus
wait where's the i remember seeing like
one that was so small maybe it was the
nano that yeah that's the one i had like
off-brand kind of
mp3 players
you know
it was cool the zoom
then there was the ipod video which was
really cool it was like the first time
you could watch videos as well
anyway
rest in peace steve jobs
you know he deserved better
i mean he invented the iphone for crazy
sake you know i mean wow that's [ __ ]
crazy bro that guy made
the iphone
shout out to his family crazy huh
that is pretty crazy it is i'm being
socratic but it is pretty crazy
so we have uh we've got we have actually
uh a uh eulogy of sorts oh we do yeah
prepared yeah i mean you remember the
ipod commercials where like yeah we do
the colored backgrounds and like it
would be like silhouettes
yeah
yeah this was super iconic
they used to run these oh yeah i do
remember that yeah
so
you know
pretty sick as i'm not even gonna lie
um it's kind of
genius how the ipod anyway anyway we
made our own eulogy to say goodbye oh
yeah so sweet well it's in real time
actually yeah so let's do it so it would
you like to step uh over to the green
screen real quick sure
do i have one swirl around oh don't
worry we have that covered as well
oh yeah
what what
i think you got to step forward a little
bit i think it works better when you're
forward
[Music]
yeah there you go okay there you go
wait hold on these sweatshops
oh no
[Music]
how did you guys do this
oh the
magic we slip we slaved away like those
apple workers uh getting this set up
[Music]
such fond memories yeah
oh this is just a nostalgia trip right
now
oh
no don't get that oh no
we're killing the vibe here
[Music]
you know steve jobs would be proud he
was around him
what the hell
that's another going good rapper bye
[Music]
bye
okay
[Music]
i love this new instagram filter
[Music]
riots unalive and others issues and
foxconn iphone seriously why those are
real
now the new supplier was using child
labor but took three years to cut ties
[Music]
oh apple denies breaking labor laws in
china on the heels of watchdog report
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
oh yeah oh yeah get it ethan
[Laughter]
that was fantastic
farewell
to the beautiful and always ethical
apple you're pouring water like a candle
it's so slow and cucumber
extreme angle
i finally watched that trick
pretty funny right yeah have i have you
guys seen it they'll just say it's fake
or something did you talk about it on
the show no i haven't
there's a video of uh kendall jenner
cutting a cucumber you saw that
i'm like this one this lady has
never caught anything in her life
she made it like harder the way that she
was like grabbing the back of the
cucumber let's pull it up i think i saw
it on uh death noodles instagram close
the trunk
did you just find it kim is that it
i think so yeah yeah cam said let me
drop it in i mean
man that's the goat
yeah def is the gu he's always got it
i mean
again i don't watch the show and i don't
support the family but
this video was pretty funny oh we're
gonna get clayton for sure oh right
right
yeah [ __ ] this not worth getting claimed
over yeah they're cleaning everything
all right i'm closing the trunk
oh
this story is so
dope [ __ ] this tick tock user named
thin frog
is creating this freak million frog army
that's gonna like destroy the entire
state he's in do we know what state he's
in i hope he's not near us
i don't why i thought i had heard i
don't think it's even in the united
states
okay thank god yeah
he's about to unleash biological terror
on
wherever he lives why i'll show you so
um
wait is it the tick tock page
why is tick tock playing a video on this
page it's just the worst it's just it's
just so stupid yeah their their
uh
desktop browser version is a complete
mess
i'm sure their traffic is like 99.99
so
on may 7th thin frog stated
they have a estimated
1.4 million frogs
that they're raising
and they have two to three weeks before
they're fully grown
so 35
uh
come on now
you're the biggest social media app in
the world get your [ __ ] together
wait we need audio
the video is not even playing
it's a delay
but it's i'm playing it on the tv why is
there
now it's playing double
yeah why why is it playing devil because
this [ __ ]
browser version of their app is dog [ __ ]
okay so that's just them
the audio's not coming from my computer
[Laughter]
is going on all right let me just start
over oh you have a window behind it
there yeah oh yeah
over there wait but why
because it felt like it i don't know
okay
here maybe i think this is it
so he says uh
basically he's been drips
is not enough for a frog army and i came
across a big bunch of friends
and died very soon
and it was also polluted
with oil
they're going to create the biggest frog
army in history so follow along to sea
like and see the frog army well just
wait this is the origins fire
i've now saved 60 clutches of frog's car
so in estimation there is 520 000 frog
eggs
is this enough
so he's searching some kind of riverbed
that's drying up where the eggs are
going to die
and he's just finding as many frog eggs
as possible
and apparently he has access to
a really big swamp
or
a swimming pool or something
he may have an ulterior motive it might
be alex jones we don't know
but so here's the result of basically
rescuing all these frog
eggs
why was this 67 days ago now i say
lots of buckets of frog spawn from
drying up and i estimated one point from
so these are the tadpoles look at this
[ __ ] oh my god
so i'm wondering how is he feeding 1.4
million
tadpoles
i have loved frogs for years and i was
never allowed to have a frog so now i've
decided to have 1.4 million
what do you guys think about this
this is going to be ecological disaster
1.4 million i i have a feeling it's a
little bit of a troll because it's like
this guy
like he has all like this equipment he's
got like this big pool
like i feel like this guy
knows about frogs
like right maybe he's hopefully because
if not yeah this is like horribly
irresponsible
like what is this well the eggs are
gross and gooey yeah
but that's what they look like
i just hope that it's a
you know just an exaggeration of numbers
i doubt there's 1.4 million right but
like maybe tens of thousands but even
then is it enough to support that tiny
lake enough to support all that oh hell
no yeah he's just gonna have a bunch of
dead frogs i'm guessing i mean the eggs
were all
they were all laid in the river but i
don't think
naturally they would all come to be
right through the metamorphosis when
they turn into full-grown frogs that's
why they plant so many of them
but what do you feed a tadpole can you
look that up like what did they live off
of because how the [ __ ] could you feed
that many murder animals okay chill
we're trying to save animals keemstar
get your
come on
animals die
well let's see what's the newest update
all right we're going to have a frog
army
so there's no update past this
um
that's crazy 70 days since i started my
frog army
i've rescued 1.4 million troops
we're going to have a big frog army
and it's very hard work because lots of
feeding and cleaning but it's very worth
it and i just remember my karen neighbor
has a phobia of frogs
well
if it's revenge i get at least
understand that
tadpoles will eat greens including
lettuce
broccoli or baby spinach wow healthy
healthy legends
it is best to rinse and freeze these
before feeding just general greens well
that's easy enough to feed i don't know
how i mean
murderer okay damn keemstar chill
what do you guys think pretty
interesting i guess i'm kind of scared
about like what uh
cam was saying like
there's just gonna be a bunch of dead
frogs at the end
oh that would be sad yeah
i don't know i don't know
i guess they'll just ravage whatever
ecosystem they're in and just like
destroy
crops and whatever the natural habitat
is you know that's the other possibility
it is cool i agree someone says it is
really a cool experiment he might be
breaking the law i don't know
i have no idea i'll look it up
i wish i knew where he was
but i'm definitely gonna be yeah it is a
plague wasn't that one of the plagues
where it rains from yeah
maybe he's god
um
well
one time we transplanted 200 frogs from
a lake and a national forest to another
area to spread population
and it wasn't strictly legal
i don't know
as cool as this is
it does seem like a ticking time bomb
yeah this is how humanity ends mary
sands said that's very possible
um
so alex says a lot of frogs will eat
each other but they sound like healthy
kings they broccoli
wait that was about the tadpole
the frogs them yeah the tadpole i don't
know what the frogs eat frogs eat other
frogs
the puffer fish right the one that turns
into a circle
no keemstar
this guy doesn't get a thing man just
keep your opinions to yourself you're
such an idiot i don't even know what to
google for the legality of this like can
i make
can i grow 10 million for hundreds right
we need to call our our lawyer back
right what's the legal limit of fraud
[Laughter]
um anyway really exciting stuff there to
follow
[Applause]
yeah
okay dan you're finally gonna have your
moment we're gonna do joe biden is on
the astral plane all right
in fact do you want to lead this segment
you've been
dan's been riding me
all week to talk about joe biden is on
the astral plane
right so yeah you want to lead this
well people probably aren't aware
um
but
big news joe biden has actually uh been
cloned
and um
uh is that clone
the real joe biden
has for a long time now he's he's
actually ascended to the astral plane
what is the astral plane
what is the astral plane yeah what is it
i don't know what that is
well it's a state of it's sort of
i don't want to say an alternate
dimension it's more like a parallel
dimension i guess okay how do you think
about it
um how do you send someone there
um there are multiple methods uh i
believe
um i believe it's like a level eight uh
wizard spell
okay so you need a wizard
you need a win yeah you or somebody
that's familiar with the arcane arts
yeah okay
you want to switch spot yeah you can you
lost me a wizard what are we talking
about but so people actually believe
this right that that's the thrust of
this
yeah people that aren't
[ __ ] asleep
people that aren't sheep no but for real
is this something that people believe
uh yeah well
there's uh
there's one person at least who believes
it and
uh that person is you yeah this just
came across my uh my timeline i mean
here here's what what set me down the
rabbit hole is i just i saw this okay
the real joe biden is on astral plane
and he's sorry for what his clone is
doing
yeah that's the same dude but just like
40 years apart right this is the real
joe biden
they don't believe in aging yeah they
don't
they don't believe in aj you're okay dan
um
oh you can't see this okay hold on one
sec
oh i see
here we go
there you are
the real joe biden is on the astral
plane
can you can you guys see it i can see
yeah you know
[Applause]
is this what wally was warning us about
while he peeled and wake up oh oh joe
biden wake up from oh very soon go to
hell
wake up oh my god i didn't even oh my
god i didn't wake up all right so take
us down the rabbit hole dan teach us
yeah okay um so
this is a really reputable source this
is from the website i frequent all the
time 41st10.com
four wins is that like a fart four times
because i started googling around i was
like i need more information why is joe
biden on the astral plane and why is he
sorry for what his clone's doing
and man it led me to this website um
there's a few websites but as far as i
could tell this was this essay here
by the great uh patrick h uh bellringer
bell ringer
got him yeah
so you know he has a long diatribe here
about uh did you read all this
i skimmed it okay
um i'm trying to find the specific part
where
oh i see i was confused at first but
yeah here we go all
right so he calls himself any good
readers readers of four wins are
discouraged worried and fearful and even
feeling hopeless about your world and
your country understandable
it's a dark time in this country right
now the problems are many and the
solutions never seem to come the
zionists
appear to be closing in with each new
day and closing the dark energies are
controlling the us government their evil
plan is to control the cosmos
and they think that they have one
however the light workers those are the
good guys uh obviously
uh have made tremendous difference in
their plans and they thwarted so many of
them that they're starving for evil food
which they cannot find right now do you
know what's happening this is the
beginning of a down the rabbit hole
video right
so many others in the u.s government
clones surrounded by the clone biden
and he's controlled and only doing what
the masters demand
of course there are some claims that
he's being misled misled by
disinformation there's two misled's
there
uh or mind controlled or even poisoned
by the deep state to do their bidding
this is true
uh for the real right to confirm this
this is true for the real biden is on
the astral plane and sorry for what his
controlled clone is doing so at least
he's you know he's this guy knows a lot
right guess what
what's the economy right
across the academy hurts
nobody uh he can tell us uh right now
that most of the people on earth at this
time are clones oh any clones in the
building right now
anybody i mean with a colony we're in
our program to acknowledge that kind of
question yeah
a big
lie
all right so is this going somewhere
uh it's just a very unwell man uh
perfect all very well
perhaps or perhaps we're all crazy and
um he's the only one but i do but there
i did uh there was some follow-up um
and some good news
the clone is now under house arrest
joe biden's claw
is under house arrest theory supported
by this one image
take a look take a look at his back here
what's going on that is what the [ __ ]
what are those
joe biden what are those
is that an orthopedic shoe or something
did he did he hurt his i think he uh i
think that this was a photo from when he
yeah i think he broke his ankle or
something playing with his dog is what
that's right i remember that yeah
yo he's got they've got like crazy ankle
technology that us plebs don't have like
i have never seen a cast like that yeah
what the [ __ ] is that but then again it
could just be a big cover for the fact
that he's wearing an ankle he's just
wearing the new yeezys
right
yeah he's getting inspiration
from joe biden's
[ __ ] ankle broken
yo what season are those those are fire
unreleased
no he's clearly on house arrest walking
around on the street
it looks like he's got a button on the
lip you remember those but you remember
those shoes you would fill up with air
and you push the button it looks like
you got one of those on the front oh
like the pump the puff yes yeah
whatever happened to those
high-tech
um too high-tech do people still make
those i don't think they're good shoes
and they don't stop
the pump-ups
those were like really desirable yeah oh
yeah who made those new balance is that
it was i never had one i've heard about
i think everyone made one at the time
yeah oh yeah yeah nike pumps here they
are pull it up
yeah let's pull it up
oh reebok reebok it looks like nike may
have had one too everyone had them they
were the craze my dude
the pump what would actually happen
it would just fill
some part of the shoe with air make it
tighter right and then you could release
it it was a total gimmick
yeah
well there you go so yeah i mean i just
there really isn't much to this but
let's do your own research people will
you read the bullet points there
um in case you haven't figured this out
biden was only the latest clone who
wanted the white house research joe
biden clone people are figuring this
stuff out not easy but it is doable
uh biden clone puts all his weight on
the broken foot
but i see that that's the real god thing
the proof that he's under austerity
right okay let's go on
i'm uneasy
the shocking photo shows biden clone
cannot keep its focus on the official
script
that biden has a quote broken ankle
right so the theory isn't even that it's
house arrest it's just that he's putting
his weight on the broken ankle oh my god
right
oh and like no human would do that
so he's got to be yeah he's got to be a
clone under house arrest
joe biden clone puts all weight on a
broken ankle he i don't really think
that that should be its own bullet point
because he didn't kind of say that right
this image is proof that the binding
clone is not have a broken ankle once
again this this bullet point also
appears to just be reiterating
and then the last bullet point is just
the word research how did you find this
this is kind of deep stuff
how did how did we get it i love
research i saw that post
uh on twitter somewhere okay so the
original one here
and i just
googled this phrase the bill joe biden
he's on the astral plane and it led me
to all these conspiracy websites which
i i think that there's a good chance
that they're all run by the same person
like this one is one news
is there a chance this is parody of so
of any kind
um
no so we're having work into a priority
i don't think yeah i mean having uh
gone down a lot of these like really
deep conspiracy rabbit holes as you know
i kind of have a mild obsession with
that kind of stuff i just i've explained
to you the crater earth theory recently
i mean later that was like it's greater
i won't change my life that is
i'm still laughing at research yeah yeah
well
do it we could do a whole segment on
crater earth if you like sometime i
would love that which one is that so
crater earth is a new one they think
flat earthers are idiots
i love that the truth is that our whole
world is inside of a deep crater
on a bigger planet right now
so they've kind of one-up the flat
earthers in a way it's like the flat
earthers are are still asleep they don't
realize are we is the surface of our
crater curved
i think that the the the globe that
we're on that the crater rests on is so
vast and so massive that though there is
some curvature it's not really enough to
be perceptible
you know but they are kind of an
offshoot of flat earth
see like our
understanding of what the world is is
flat but it's just one
area on a much bigger globe okay yeah so
again they've sort of leapfrog because
this is like the next pokemon evolution
exactly like that it's exactly like that
and when we look out at the moon at
night that's a reflection of the real
earth
oh that's right yeah i remember dan sent
me the videos and i went down the rabbit
hole too yeah okay
yeah and ally actually i credit to my
girlfriend ally she discovered she
brought crater earth to my attention
when she is working at home drawing her
favorite pastime is to go
it's not even youtube she's realized
you've got to go off youtube to get to
the really good [ __ ] there's this
website uh bit shoot where it's like
everybody who's been banned from youtube
uh goes to post their conspiracy theory
stuff and it was like a
how long was it it was like a whole
[ __ ] documentary this guy there's
like a 20-part series it's like a
20-part series on crater earth i love
the dedication it's very imaginative
it's a fun fun sci-fi that people
unfortunately lose their mind to but
yeah
outside of uh did you how much should
you watch
all of you yeah i watched i got i don't
know first five episodes
pretty deep it really doesn't get good
until episode 12.
i mean he does a pretty adequate job of
explaining it right off the bat and it's
like well maybe i'll go revisit it but
it was right it's fun sci-fi
i see there's some hollow earth gang uh
people in our uh
chat that's another one i'm less
familiar about hollow earth but i know
that that's one off
why does that sound like a video game
well there's been a lot of
literature about the earth being hollow
and [ __ ] but oh that that one is the
dumbest of all because
i mean that's just how gravity works
that one's kind of hard to explain the
hollow earth i mean just dig down dummy
just dig a hole then
if the earth's solid then just dig a
hole you [ __ ] idiot i mean you say
that that's not how gravity works but
what are you basing your knowledge of
how gravity is right right
based on what do you know based on this
on six point
research here yeah
six point research it's the highest form
of research do the re here here's
gravity
there dig a [ __ ] hole that's all you
need to know
well i think i think the hollow earth
gravity theory is that we're on the
inside of the earth and it's spinning oh
we're inside right and it's like the
centrifugal force we're inside the earth
right now
right and and and this centrifugal for
like imagine you're like on the inside
of like a um you know one of those uh g
force yeah yeah simulators or whatever
so imagine you're on the inside surface
of the earth it's spinning so fast how
do they explain day time
i haven't i haven't gotten that part of
the documentary
right now dude that's [ __ ] crazy
hey jack sorry about my clone
[Laughter]
he's feeling real bad after a plane
i'm digging my clone man my clones all
up to no kind of good trouble there with
the hairy legs
eating all that ice cream [ __ ] come on
my clone is just out of control
i was gonna put him in uh
all right i'm gonna wrap it up
how long we've been going uh two and a
half hours
all right guys so remember oh we got a
new quartering tweet what is this
hang on before we wrap it up i got an
emergency
uh quartering tweet
after the wife's emergency landing
she caught a ride with another pilot in
a cub
to go get her tools from our hanger
female pilot privilege
the moral of the swords i don't have to
go pick her up and i'm getting to play
video games
what the [ __ ] did i just read
dumb ian just sent this where did you
even come across is there context that
i'm missing
what's the context of this
after the wife's emergency landing
she caught a ride with another pilot and
a cub
to go get her tools from our hanger
female
pilot privilege
this is harder to decode than this
guy's website what's the context on the
subreddit ian can you send uh
the post to me to try to figure out what
what what i'm reading yeah
they said apparently her she had to land
her plane because she had an engine
issue and then some someone else came
and picked her up and jeremy stayed home
to play video games
where where's jeremy fit in this story
he didn't want to go oh this is his wife
okay so his wife summer had emergency
landing
and she caught a ride isn't it
violent
evidently
she has a plane i think people in the
chat have pointed out the cub is
probably supposed to a misspelling of
cab
oh
okay let me read this again oh decode
yeah let's think about this okay let me
read this out somebody said cub is a
plane i don't know
my wife went out for pizza without me
cub equals type of plane okay well maybe
okay let's try now she's going for tools
without him
so after my wife's emergency landing she
caught a ride from another pilot
to go get her tools from our hanger
female
pilot privilege
the moral of the story is i don't have
to go pick her up
so the fact that he adds female does
that mean that a male pilot gave her a
ride oh definitely
you know you get that crotch rot
the moral destroyers i don't have to go
pick her up and i'm just kidding
cubby's a type of plane it sounds like
you're saying the cub is a plane type
how many pilots do we have in the
audience there's like 30 people are like
sounds
club is a piper j3 cup
how do you know that
it sounds to me like this that his wife
is getting [ __ ]
railed by this pilot
and he's just playing video games well
it's the fact that he wrote female pilot
privilege it's like he tweeted about it
at all
like what are you talking about bro why
are you worried about my wife this is
very weird
weird
what's happening in that hangar what is
ethan their
their relationship is just weird now
like what kind of tools is she getting
thanks yeah
and he's like i get to play video games
tell me about it later honey
nah bro i don't like jeremy either
why would you tweet this he's like why
he's he's so embarrassing
i don't know how
i don't know how anyone married this man
i mean
there's so many in the drain there's so
many pilots we have like
a quarter of our audience is pilots
apparently shout out to our pilots
everybody's flying planes around
all right so pilots
who are watching let's take a poll
is his wife getting getting pipe this is
only for pilots
only if you know what a cub is
[Laughter]
she caught a ride with another pilot in
a cub to go get her tools from our
hanger
how's she getting home still what do you
mean
in the airplane
is he going to land in front of your
house why don't you have to pick up your
wife again
i'm confused
he's not relieved that the emergency
landing was was a success just that he
used to play video games you know
it's
i'm deep undercover
all right okay
okay so we have the pole his wife
getting piped by this other pilot oh i
misspelled it wow no only one percent
jeremy you need to see the results of
this but only 56 percent of our audience
is not pilots
yeah no uh i have a plan i didn't tell
you
our audience no i was playing yeah i own
a plane in a hangar incredible
jeremy you're in trouble buddy
only two percent say no your wife is not
getting piped basically irrefutable
evidence
dude you are in big trouble jeremy
you just tweeted out that your wife is
going out to pizza without you
and by pizza i mean getting [ __ ]
and by [ __ ] which means tools from a
hangar yeah i know what that means
tools from a hanger i know
interesting comment flight attendant
here pilots are cheaters
there you have it
and that concludes it there's [ __ ] all
over the floor i would call that comment
research number six
wow jeremy you gotta
i don't know man i think if i was
jeremy's wife i'd be looking elsewhere
once he built that brie larson shed
that's pretty that would see the deal
for me
the significant other you know 50 videos
i'm jerking off in my brie larson shed
tonight
i'm not taking a pause to [ __ ] all over
the floor
all right so
guys tomorrow
if you want to join us for our stream of
watching the fight
become a member
we're gonna be having lots of fun
tomorrow
starting at three
we'll be going for hours it will be
available as a vaude for members right
yeah i kept seeing people ask that and
uh yes it won't just be like a one-off
it'll it'll the vaude will be saved
after the stream so if you're not able
to catch it live and you want to watch
the fight later
uh we are
you just rip ass
[Laughter]
that was so loud that was so loud could
you guys hear it like on mike i wonder
who shredder
that was so loud holy [ __ ]
someone's like sam if you know who that
is
what happened
she was in shock
that was not a sound bite
there's no way i was trying to figure
out if that was a sound bite or not
what's the big deal i read that dropped
it happens i dropped the grumpy in my
pants dude it was loud it was loud like
a tool and a hanger kind of loud
why'd you do your time on that one i'm
back to uh
jokes guys
i get in the habit of farting as loud as
possible because theodore thinks it's
funny no he doesn't yes he does he loves
it stop lying to yourself your brain and
watch him
and so
most people fart quietly i used to but
now i put i force it out and try to
make it live you're ready for denny's
now
that's true
yeah somewhere theodore's laughing
enjoy
all right so guys become a member
we'll see you
tomorrow it's gonna be super fun abs
gonna
you can take the dub i guess i should
just say it to say it i think most
people understand this but we will not
be showing the fight it will just be us
reacting to it so if you you'll have to
use your own ticket to the fight this is
a companion stream or you can just watch
that or just use your imagination
yeah you can i mean we'll we'll be we'll
give him a play by play
we'll describe it yeah
someone said ethan you're losing it this
is not normal well you know what normal
people don't [ __ ] entertain you like
this okay
if i was a normal person this would be a
boring show and you wouldn't be watching
it
so therefore
reason to fart really loud yes confirmed
that's what happens at home
what the heck and dog
all right so we'll see you guys tomorrow
uh if not if you guys won't be there
we'll talk all about it on monday
but i look forward to seeing you guys
tomorrow
and uh thank you guys have a great
weekend
um
that's it let's go get them
hey b go go knock them let's go
let's go
let's go right now
with all the guests you'll see the best
podcast in the world take it from me
baby we podcast now
you're watching h to the three three
three three three you're watching h to
the three three three three you're
watching h to the three three three
three three you're watching h to the
three three three three three my drinks
are mayweather